من جهه اخرى اعلنا جهاز امن الدوله
الفيدراليه الروسيه ان المخابرات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه كانت تستعد لشن هجوم على اراضي
روسيا باستخدام ما تسمى بالقنبله القذره
واضاف ان تحقيق فيما سماها عمليه تخريبيه
في مطار سيفريني كشف خطط اوكرانيا لشن هذا
الهجوم وكشف جهاز امن الدوله ان رئيس
الاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه انشا
خدمه منفصله لتزويد مجموعات التخريب
والاستطلاع في روسيا بالاسلحه والمسيرات
ووفقا للجهاز امن الدوله الروسي فان
المجموعات التي كونتها اوكرانيا نفذت خمسه
طلعات جويه في روسيا منذ بدايه العمليه
من جو خضار ابدا مع كيكرمان اخر المعلومات
حول مستوى المياه الان واين وصلت عمليات
اجلاء السكان هناك
تحدثت عن قصف اوكراني مستمر لتلك المنطقه
الواقعه في مقاطعه خرسون هذا الامر وهذه
المحطه كنا تحدثنا عن ارتباطها بتامين ومد
المياه لشبه جزيره القرم التاكيدات من
السلطات المحليه انا مستويات المياه في
شبه جزيره القرم لغايه الان لم تتاثر ولكن
هذا الامر يجب مراقبته في الساعات الماضيه
في ساعات المقبله عفوا وقبل قليل كان هناك
اعلان من عمده مقاطعه من عمده شبه جزيره
القرمو حاكم شبه جزيره القرم الموالي
لروسيا الذي اكد ان الاوضاع مستقره يمكن
القول بالنسبه لامدادات المياه لشبه جزيره
القرم هذه المنطقه التي كانت قد عانت على
مدى سنوات من انقطاع للمياه جراء قطع
السلطات الاوكرانيه للمياه عام 2014 بعد
ضم روسيا لشبه جزيره القرم اليها واليوم
هناك مخاوف بعد استهداف هذه المحطه وهذا
السد ان يعود هذا السيناريو ويتكرر على
اهالي تلك المنطقه هذا من جهه من جهه اخرى
فيما خص منسوب المياه هناك حديث عن مترين
ثلاثه او حتى اكثر من ذلك ولكن اخر الصور
التي تريدنا سهام من تلك المنطقه ومحيط
كخوفكا امتار غمرات بعض المباني السكنيه
وحتى بعض الصور تظهر وصول هذه المياه الى
وسط المدن في تلك المنطقه اذا منسوب
المياه مرجح للارتفاع في الساعات المقبله
ولكن عمده المدينه يقول انه في غضون يومين
او ثلاثه من المفترض ان تعود هذه
المنسوبات الى سابق عهدها اليوم
سهام مع هذا الاستهداف تم الحديث والتذكير
بمجره في الايام الماضيه وربطه امر
استهداف هذا السد بقيام عدد من القوات
الاوكرانيه بزوارق محاولاتها عبور نهر
دنيبر وهذا الامر وضع في اطار الاستهداف
الاوكراني والدلالات التي استخدمها البعض
في التاكيد على ان القوات الاوكرانيه هي
المسؤوله عن تدمير هذا السد اليوم ايضا في
اخر المعطيات التي ترد من هذه المحطه
الكهرومائيه التي تزود اخرسون وعدد من
المناطق في جنوب اوكرانيا بالكهرباء تم
الحديث عن قطع هذه او انقطاع الكهرباء عن
عدد من هذه المناطق والمدن والقرى في
خرسون وجوارها نعم كار